Apple's WWE DC event just ended and wow
I've got to tell you guys I was totally
Blown Away by some of the things that
Apple showed us and no it wasn't Craig
federighi running in slow mo we're
talking things like the new M2 MacBook
Air the lack of a Mac Pro and where the
heck is the Mac Mini as well as some
awesome new features that I totally
wasn't expecting so in this video I'm
going to talk about the leaks and
predictions that I got totally wrong I'm
sorry guys like the whole white bezels
and white keyboard thing but I did get
some things right including the M2 chips
performance I can't believe I got it
that close anyway let's get right into
the video now for the last few months
I've been giving you guys bits and
pieces of my predictions on the M2
MacBook Air as well as the M2 Chip and
in February I actually worked with
renders by Shailesh to create these
renders of the MacBook Air and I'm
actually very happy with how close we
got first of all we got the whole white
keyboard white bezels wrong
unfortunately I also thought that the
keyboard well would match the bezels but
it's actually not because it's color
matched there's no MacBook Air text on
the little chin area so I got that right
but I thought it would be on the bottom
engraved just like the MacBook Pro but
it's not there is nothing on the bottom
I'm also very happy that I got the
rounded bottom design like the new
Macbook Pro so that is just exactly how
I thought it would be and I told you
guys it would be much thinner just big
enough for the ports to fit so that was
correct as well as the four little
stands just like the MacBook Pro now
what I got wrong was that I thought
there would be one Thunderbolt port on
each side but no they're both on the
same side right next to the max save 3
that we all expected but what I really
love is that Apple color matched the max
save 3 cable and it's braided it's just
beautiful now now what also was telling
you guys that Apple would give us better
battery life with the M2 Chip even
though it's going to be significantly
thinner which is crazy because there's a
20 reduction in volume and it's
literally less than half an inch thick I
cannot believe they got it that thin
that might even be thinner than I
personally expected now I personally
thought that there would be more color
options for the MacBook Air and I
thought that Apple would take the subtle
route with a very light blue but they
actually went the opposite way they gave
us a standard silver space gray but they
gave us this new champagne-ish Starlight
which Mark German got totally right as
well as the dark blue midnight which is
actually darker than the space gray
which is very very interesting and I
absolutely love that color but one of my
predictions that I am very very happy
that I got correct was the actual
MacBook lineup because I was telling you
guys for a while that the M1 MacBook Air
would stick around for around the same
price price and yes it's still a
thousand dollars and the M2 MacBook Air
11.99 so twelve hundred dollars and of
course 1300 for the M2 MacBook Pro and
then of course we have the 14 and 16
inch but I absolutely can't believe how
close I was with my performance
predictions for the M2 Chip but before
we jump right into that I want to ask
you guys to click subscribe because
we're gonna be getting our hands on
these new Macbook Pros and comparing
them to basically all of the other
MacBooks and as you guys know we do the
most in-depth and detailed comparisons
out there so please subscribe and by the
way to celebrate the new M2 Chip we
actually worked with basic apple guy on
Twitter to create this new M2 Chip
design so definitely check that out and
if you want to support us be sure to
pick up one of those because we have
sweatshirts or should I say hoodies and
we have T-shirts and be sure to use the
coupon code M2 Chip with no space for 20
off on all of our merch for a limited
time now jumping right into the
performance I made a video Back In
December talking about the different
scenarios for the M2 Chip now I had two
scenarios the first one is that the M2
is based on the a15 chip and the second
scenario is that it's going to be based
on the a16 ship with the new 4 nanometer
process now Apple just let us know that
it's based on the a15 which is second
generation five nanometer all right now
according to Apple the CPU is up to 18
faster and the GPU is up to 35
faster so as you can see in my
predictions right here in the screenshot
you can see that the M2 Chip based on
a15 I predicted
87.38 now if I take out the calculator
and I multiply the M1 chip performance
by
1.18 which is 18 percent look at that 8
800 I am literally within
62 points so I'm so happy that I got
that close for the multi-core CPU
performance of course based on the a15
now let's go over to the metal graphics
performance so Apple said the M2 is 35
faster in terms of the GPU because of
the 10 cores well let's add 35 to the
performance of the M1 ship and as you
can see 28
579.5 look at that I am within around
300 points in terms of the metal GPU
performance so I'm very happy about that
and we're definitely gonna have to test
the actual performance when we get them
in so don't forget to subscribe now
getting back to the M2 MacBook Air there
were a couple things that really really
surprised me first of all I was not
expecting it to go up to 24 gigabytes of
RAM that was a total shocker to me now
on top of that I wasn't expecting Apple
to give the M2 Chip 100 gigabytes per
second of memory bandwidth which is 50
more than the M1 especially since
they're still only using two RAM chips
on the M2 Chip which means really good
things for the M2 Pro M2 Max and M2
Ultra that are coming later but one
thing that really blew my mind was that
they were adding the prores video and
code and decode engines and not only
that but 8K prores as well as 8K hevc
and h.264 which I was not expecting at
all but in terms of the downsides I
can't believe we still only have Wi-Fi 6
and Bluetooth
5.0 and on top of that it still only
supports One external display which I
got wrong because I didn't think Apple
would do that again but they did it so
it looks like they're keeping that
limitation there just so that the higher
end MacBooks will be there to support
more displays and now with that said
let's pivot over to the Mac Mini because
we were expecting a new redesigned M2
Mac Mini in a thinner form factor and
design and we obviously didn't get that
at ww DC now personally I think there's
a chance that apple is sticking to just
one redesigned product per event because
if we go all the way back to April of
2021 Apple redesigned the iMac and it
was by itself and then in the fall of
2021 we had the 14 and 16 inch MacBook
Pros redesigned that was just by itself
then going up to March we had the new
Mac Studio which is a new design by
itself and now at WWDC we have the new
Macbook Air redesigned by itself because
the MacBook Pro uses the old design so
what if Apple's preparing another event
in the fall potentially in November to
show us the redesign of the M2 Mac Mini
now I think that would make sense
because the Mac Mini is cheap right now
it's only 700 and we're expecting this
new M2 Mac Mini to replace the current
M1 at around the same price point so
what if Apple wants to sell these more
expensive M2 MacBooks first before they
release the M2 Mac Mini in the fall so
that they can get as much money as
possible from these laptops and then
they can show off the desktop Mac Mini
later with its new redesign as well but
in terms of the Mac Pro we are all very
disappointed because I was hoping for a
teaser kind of like a one more thing
thing for the Mac Pro and now that we
didn't get anything about it I'm
starting to worry that we might actually
not get it for a while because Ming
Chico was saying the Mac Pro the iMac
Pro and the Mac Mini might not come
until 2023 and that was a very bold
addiction because everybody was
expecting the Mac Pro this year and
there are so many leaks of it actually
coming out so let me share with you guys
what I think happened well I think it
could have gotten delayed potentially
because of the hardware flaw that we
exclusively talked about recently on
Twitter where there's an issue where the
M1 Ultra is scaling very very badly
because of a limitation with the tlb or
kind of like the buffer memory so what
if that led Apple to delay that version
until they could get that fixed and base
it off of the M2 family it shifts
instead of the M1 maybe that happened
and what if we don't get it until next
year well there's still a chance that
this fall apple comes out and boom they
give us the Mac Pro because technically
Apple's two-year transition for Apple
silicon began in November of 2020 when
we got the M1 chip Max so so it could
finish in November with a Mac Pro reveal
which I tweeted about back in January so
hopefully that happens but there is a
chance that if there were a lot of
issues Apple could just delay it but
let's hope for the best but talking
about the M2 MacBook Air I think Apple
absolutely nailed it especially since it
is incredibly thin and beautiful so I
think Apple's gonna sell a ton of these
and I don't think anybody should buy the
new M2 MacBook Pro don't buy that it's a
waste of money with the old design
You're Gonna Want This MacBook Air so
with that said hopefully you enjoy this
video and if you did go ahead and click
the circle above to subscribe definitely
check out one of those two videos right
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]